sighs over hip-hop ninety-two three
through after-party been bootlegged
Kevin my guy sitting next to me DJ
damage we got a special guest yo rich
homie is back yes yes yes show me baby
it's back to the base is most definitely
man it's been a minute man it's been a
minute no it definitely has been a
minute bro you know I mean I just when I
wish I got derailed you know I'm saying
I want the litigation with TIG so I can
put out no music for like a year and a
half everything split right and put on
no media show like what a thing like
that record ever Anthony just by quiet
so at that time I was really just like
my legal stuff like get my my [ __ ] he's
taking care of right cause like when I
first signed TRG I was looking for way
out at that time so I wouldn't I didn't
have nobody to look over the paper
mm-hmm and it really like hurt me a
little bit little in the long run you
know I'm saying cause I had so many bit
songs man man it was automatic for you
at one peel and it's like you put your
all in there but you don't get
compensated for it so it's like not like
on my year off from lifetime do I do the
same thing do I get my all again cuz I
haven't even come scheduled for tonight
so it's like it's calling me so Danny's
like this time I just like got a
businessman friend I'm not coming in
with no feelings you know exam I know
the beach there's no I'm just smarter
he's been like at first I didn't know
man like he pretty much is looking for
in a way out and not knowing he was
gonna do what it did so yeah when he was
giving you the Birdman treatment
essentially I won't even say the Birdman
Cheeseman because I TIG like III kind of
feel bad like I don't have no hard
feelings about them personally like it
when you something bad like I just said
it I was in bro I went guerrilla and I
just different like you know it was cool
just like a lot of loopholes I didn't
know about you know I mean we're like at
the same time I'm not known as being I'm
just coming in my songs are my bags all
I know is like I got talent and I'm
saying I'm just hoping I get put in the
face situation do you kind of appreciate
it though because yeah because what I do
that what out they like you got to go
through trials and tribulations like
that that made me understand again so
probably never went through this TI's
you know gave me a chance I wanna be
here today so I still thank you don't
give me like I still owe them I got
hard feelings for them I just Vanessa I
wish I would have understood the
pegboard more your game so then I
wouldn't know what I would get myself
into one percent it's been yeah you know
I saw recently you were back hanging out
with young Doug I know you guys had a
little now for a while yeah you guys I
mean obviously lifestyles like touch it
like a minute I got classic get back
together like to be honeys man we did
like their songs oh I don't know if he's
dropping as I hate quite what you're
doing or but it's all oh we haven't got
back in the studio but right nobody
spoke with him recently right now are we
see turn the marginals I hear not
offensive like it ain't no bad blood was
the issue one-sided though because I
never really see you jump out if you
don't you went like because like man I
tried carry my cell like a boss like
different things like you're not gonna
see me do your massages always looking
like it was one side like never really
like what was the initial issue on his
Andy thank you for cuz like you know
sounds like we were never group
you ain't me independent and like that's
the way I want to still be at the end
today like I still want always do my own
thing like I never want to be considered
like a group or I never want like anyone
to feel like they helping me if anyone I
know it like what I could do is so like
I don't know that we got offended by
medias and I'm always work on my career
what not but you know sense behind a
rich gang was kind of like confusing it
was a little confusing I'm pretty oh
there's I so there's young thug this
Birdman who nobody wants to hear rap
okay yeah you know rich homie Quan and
then there was just a bunch of other
random a lot of rain getting era which
is very amusing to me because everybody
was sign of different people and like
that we never signed any paperwork so
just like sugar baby I was just having
fella that's all man that's one of the
best music comes up but maybe ego got
involved as things started to really
build up yeah because you got a thing
like man we both was already like we
came in as solo artists like 5% I know
the time you was the Buick super daddy
yeah it does yeah so it was like I just
saw a likening them you know I'm saying
I just like dang I just like little bro
let me shuttle bro like was nobody told
me when no one showed me nothing like we
had like over 100 songs together
yo man y'all [ __ ] I feel like
like you said with the TIG situation on
maybe him being so young as an artist at
that time and the way to riff is maybe
it's ego not that's maybe is his wish I
mean like yeah like don't get back like
I know bear blood like one time you
can't stop me who makes great music
that's one thing like if the maqams
moves events percent me that was about
this Birdman uh pay you for like
lifestyle in the rich king she because I
don't like Birdman pays a lot of people
[ __ ] is gonna check no yeah I got my
chin only because like my paperwork was
good so your paper will go straight with
the boot Lieberman yeah like I didn't
expect no money life for the future like
we don't you don't charge your buddies
your paperwork's crazy should get paid
by radio lifestyle was like for you it
was like doing a feature reckon I
overdid it with you when I first when I
first met but like this is my first time
mean burger they already had a song like
the song to hit what I me on the right
he's I'm saying so when I get after I
meet Birdman for the part time I come
back to the studio and if you look at
something you check it so I check it out
I hop on it right there two weeks later
don't master the mix on radio things
like it's been like it was I didn't
lighten after day after the lifestyle I
think that's what we did the tape he did
a whole kit but you got to keep in mind
prior to that man throw already been
working like before I even drop some
type of way we are we working like
studio every day so we got time this
means 100% I know you a little bit that
everybody was just ready to count you
out
all right before flex drop everybody's
like we know rich homies done you'll see
people talking and throwing jabs that
everybody you know bother me man only
because like I knew what I had like I
know what I got you know something like
it's like it was dead you feeling my
like I really feeling they put me in
that tough it was just gonna put that in
there alone you know you just dropped
your biggest song as a career and at
that time I'm thinking like some type of
way to walk through my biggest song but
hey yeah just give me a yeah yeah yeah
the kind of center problem like Marlon
was such a beast without problems the
song would not have been with it being
like I paint he came up with a walk to
work I had like a tone but walk through
that's what me werewolves like I kind of
you got to get problems credit he Carell
it really got killed by you can problem
it's not the problem you know I'm saying
like straight up I don't get a lot of
credit like that he deserves you can
probably speaking pain the famous are
dim he brought something out of me I
didn't know was in me do you feel like
you're kind of playing catch-up now
because uh you know over the last you
know year like you said you couldn't
play make music for the stated period of
time and during that time period I feel
like your your peers have kind of
whether it's Travis scholars or Doug
amigos over here I mean like all these
guys you Elena
you've been chilling quiet not putting
on new music and you're watching the me
goes go on a whole nother level is on
another level yeah
was it frustrating sitting on the bed
when so much is first-rate man but like
hang on like it was frustrating because
like you're doing so many songs you know
you got songs you just can't release
them yeah and you can't let the people
know what cuz you know because of legal
stuff you can't talk about it it's
frustrating but at the same time it's
motivation because you know these do you
know I'm saying you don't being with
these two you know that you came for the
same stuff you just waiting on your
chance again I'm just waiting to jump is
like you know house guys don't do way to
jump back in I once they give me my turn
when I get my time just do the best I
know what I'm gonna do with my
opportunity when I get but the people
you just named it you know Kevin's name
y'all kind of created that new energy
with these new artists to work together
you know if it wasn't that new Atlanta
if it wasn't you Travis Scott amigos all
y'all working together where you do I
think a lot of these artists that are
coming out now wouldn't be so open to
collaborating yeah like I'm gonna live
like that way like it was different I
was it was real it was he wasn't even
genuine guy was like really homies in
the studios all shout PP long way to
yeah a long way feels long way you know
at a time like it went about the money
was about the music you know someone
know mean is it that so it's different
and you know I know mean that's I know
II go yeah and when that money came we
all got our own mind now when I want to
see the studio laid out wearing got to
you don't and so it is you know saying
like the minor man you know always wanna
do it every time talk about you did have
it like a moment we have done that
little diggy record yeah later - crazy
videos like Dickie mind he kind of told
me he had just reached out to you I like
I like I like literally like hit up your
Instagram like mail for futures him and
not hit me oh he hit me up and I think
so now that man just little Dickie and
keep in mind
little Dicky and you probably like my
life you know we're going right here so
like I said and go look at more I heard
the song and you can do it like when I
first heard all that to Carell you just
hear like he gonna like he riding he's
not punching in he's really skirting him
and he's a perfectionist like you know
I'm saying like we did it we did the
carny show and he messed up on the part
news out of that stage so matter like oh
no one no notice no one knows he was
like I know I know and I was like this
whole look his whole thing for the video
like it really did it worked the way he
wanted to set it up and I'm saying and
like my I sent him with 16 barbers he
really cooked my mug he cut your bursary
so I don't know my hair for the ceiling
but a paper system you ever find him
like really knows before you get my hair
made up you might hit balls on something
else you know that but nah nah nah I he
paid me the full price I'm insisting I
was expecting hit a hole 16 but the way
he did like the creatively decimated so
hard like that mean that's what made it
even harder than the 16 bar let's not
forget rich homie was so hot that after
flex came out another artist came did
the dancer yes and had a hit as well yo
and they tried to like at that time if I
clean I can no money on foot you can sue
I was like man just for me to inspire
somebody I wanted this one you want that
one wait it only reason I didn't do it
bro because I didn't want people to
think I was a dancing person 91 right
cuz like the dance just came about I was
drunk and it just happened and I said I
was in the studio one day out like the
kids going crazy so I got so I'm going
to show in Florida it might be Orlando
but I'm gonna show him Florida you're
not doing I do it a memory first when I
do this avenged I want the girls just go
so crazy my flinch came out I caught the
temple to do it with that but when he
came out at the corners on the kerosene
out but I was like I just want my fans
thanks I'm trying to become this
disability dance artists because I'm
nothing I don't do the dance at all in
the moat and I didn't want people to
paint like I didn't want people to get
them miss confused yeah I was that but I
ain't want no part like I don't want to
stop them from making money I was I was
in I was glad I can influence somebody
to make a song it been hit the corner
anybody I really want
to see on that song not kind of
definitely iPhone but yeah it would have
been good by you it would have been
great for the you play my fans I ain't
want ahead on just confuse you know
anything alright hopefully if he gets I
know that I got a dance in the weekly
schedule somewhere I heart Memphis do
you feel like you know do you see that a
lot is there a song or maybe you put out
where people kind of got your vibe
confused that gave you that kinda like
that mindset like man when I put this
one song out they thought I was trying
to sing yourself you know I like all the
time even like from to some type of way
when I first dropped that like it label
me as a some type of a artist you know
saying like this time using our
different corner well yeah I feel like
you kind of birth the whole like two
years of like just vibe you know but did
they all different vibes you can't say
some type of way sounds like my Hilda
you can't say my header sounds like walk
to they all they feelings to me is more
fulfilling I don't I don't hear the beat
I feel to be I don't hear layers I feel
to live the people that are saying these
things right then you're a type of a
person and say you know whatever are
they even your fans though it might you
know you say you know if you say hey are
your biggest fans something when you say
my fans may not understand but the
people that say this stuff our date your
fans anyway should we should we did you
even listen to these people anyway it's
not even about listen it is like I can't
even tell you right I can't sit up and
say I don't read my Cummings because I
go on the pigeons gonna be up coming and
I'm gonna read and I say I go in my
congregation everyone but whatever under
the picture of course you don't read and
you're gonna see like you don't start
questioning am i doing is right but like
I don't do that that's why I don't
really like reading I scans them I don't
get into my own reply back because then
I mean that's when it gets deep in what
it is I mean you talk to your opinion
yeah I'm a rapper but like come on I'm
not gonna be everybody favor up well you
know I'm gonna head is because we get
that music and artistry is personal yeah
it won't affect something like it is it
is some way whether you like it and I
was gonna read what wrote about this
like you go search the name you want to
see what saying about you if it's gonna
be good it's gonna be bad but you can't
edit break you know emotion was there
ever a obviously when you were going
through litigation to get free four
fingers a game was there ever a point in
time where like I feel like
QC kinda has a monopoly on everybody in
Atlanta this poppet the coach can't ever
try to reach it
we're gonna trip you out like my dad and
Pete and coach care like you see they're
so close like they so close so light
I've always just watched them you know
saying like I love the way they move but
I just felt as though they'd been
disloyal you know example me right to go
from a one independent it's another
Nippon label it's definitely gonna be
cap right now a major yeah but final bad
I know I know bad blood I love PLO to me
go they tried they try to inquire now at
that time I see I see they really
started off like at the same time you
know lyrics Trinidad James turn that
damn I TIG almond like but I was signing
first over there so I thought I would
say it's a company somewhere friendly
competition like a lemon think they both
post each other so don't like you don't
want to be Katie yeah exactly
night Katie at all but I know Katie you
don't hang but but I like it like I say
I got a good relationship you know that
I support everybody over there and I
mean we live amazing even so it is well
element what's the craziest uh obviously
you've had some very very big records
I'm sure the ladies have been hollering
at you of over the over the years what
is a groupie story that you could share
with us we're a chick was two out of
pocket or I've traded one this one I
know forget I think I'm down in Waycross
Georgia way cross it is like I can't
tell you how to get there with
expressways on this high country it is
no country so I'm coming up stage and
he's Dooley's flagging me down when we
get a picture I bet I don't want to set
your picture blaze affair so he said
well you take a picture my girl right
yeah said well keep grab a blade grabber
but yo dude any returns do that girl
that is all I know man he takes my hand
pushes on his girl but that's just like
that's not even like a groupie so just
awkward moment there's a definitely
abuse wouldn't like to get mail would be
more like some white let it be my wife
but you know
is better or maybe I'll do a TED they
have another bangbros driver today maybe
I'll do with the fence there I don't
know but I thought it was good I liked
the white people [ __ ] to do they
definitely like it was different for me
you know I mean I got too many stone at
me and I was very Kenny's not a little
claim it was just big but I thought that
was groupies only because I don't find
myself are you single are you the kind
of guy well first of all I don't know if
you're single or not but obviously are
you the kind of guy that you know dabble
in the chicks like I want to know what
happens when you take a check back to
the hotel room and in the vagina smells
like honestly like the birth question
happens like you kick around you just
get dumb guys like what is the protocol
you can call me on your corner do you
see why all you want to drink anything
like I'm a roll hit the studio see light
for while I'm out trying to be as
thirsty as I used to be okay I love you
word that Thursday night six to thirty
call ourselves why I bit so light not
time to I hope I don't get no Smith
right but sometimes yeah you don't know
so you know I know the club into sweat a
personal my baby right
you know if I'm asking on one gonna
shower together you know let's get
romantic and I mean just go from now
hopefully I'll be glad I suggest a
shower yeah you got to spill it in there
but don't you say like baby we can
totally get another gay let's take
shower together but you know she gonna
use push and it's good now you guys
imagine she watch that thing you know
that yeah yeah yeah like get in them get
enough or not you definitely get some it
well who's your favorite porn star they
obviously watch bang blah yeah not
coming up my lighters Cherokee Cherokees
the like G and J 2 Phi J to fight
yourself oh geez yeah you not to have to
like oh that's the time for like that
says that's my time for like I don't
like for them to you know so much um oh
my family teachers over like a horse is
like you Stacey still doing it you know
she probably is I said ology I know she
knows watch you're going got seven kids
right now she knows you gotta hold you
but listen I'd like to be a grandpa hard
that was
real tudo no that was really yeah her
she say fake-ass waiting the stretch
mark they're using all the beauty of
Erica not like a lot of just ongoing
fake booty crazy what rating is it like
we got me now because you're gonna like
too much good run and every [ __ ] got a
fake ass and it looks terrible
I'm so glad Kendrick Lamar said that on
this song he went here the guy I didn't
want like because I think like man he
said it right on the head like yeah it's
too much fake but I did like man I don't
like Facebook's like I want me a girl
who naturally onion gotta have only one
should have autumn follows you know
that's too much you know you can't have
a follower cut off from you realize
really like 50,000 50 - yeah I look at
like a budding actor without lights
you're not a fan you'll get excited when
you find a bad chicken she got like
around nine eight thousand five yeah
taking on my three people eyes and
following she marries donor [ __ ] on
back I'm pretty sure to use my minutes
with a lot of these diamond in the rough
that's what you saw that man are they
saving them money going to get shut up
even now we we as a crew have had this
discussion is it okay to ever pay for
[ __ ] is it ever okay they trick look I
like this what I'm sorry cuz I don't
really pay for it like here in your name
like you know you know you if you don't
get work if you're a gentleman if you're
gonna pay for the crying oh you're gonna
pay for this dumb blame I just feel as
if me being a man you don't got to do
that but at the same time I'm not gonna
put no money on hand because I'm tight
right I don't got no money on me I'm not
gonna put no money I feed you
you're gonna be good you can literally
do it so many times on you know Sam
Blake so if you looking like that you
see a pamphlet I'm not giving it a
straighter envelope like at our official
week why never been to a rub-and-tug
was like like an asian massage parlor I
never bought or it may not be people is
a happy in this map yeah a part of the
real after party whoever bid no they
have some bones in their little own
pocket to the Robin tag no but I've
always wanted to go cause of the stories
you yeah
rub hands jacking you off for $45 and
maintain the rush hour movie got me
laughs Blair so I thought those kids
were like the mom was gonna come who do
you want
so like that's I don't want nobody
misses their mitts on short ladies check
me off
yeah because it's a bullet word you
don't know but I did ii yo yo so what's
next so the basic record is out i replay
sorry is 80 I'm thinking at 80 record we
have names like the way to the back to
the babe in this mixtape yes talk about
uh like obviously you say you've been
sitting on I bet you you know you got I
think some projects on projects man I
got over 400 record a song so right now
aren't release event why you were
chillin you know sitting back anything
who some of these new artists that's
starting to coming again you want to
work with for sure I like coat it go I
like it connect in not having man you
gotta get out of trouble for something
however yes don't come out like when I'm
about to do and he get back in trouble
but I love coat like a lovely story I'd
be more into like if I can feel you as a
person to me he's got a boot like he I
feel like he's the new boozy part of the
feeling you know he would say well he
puts me in the minor when I first heard
instead old school the hot boys
Oh VG like the boys like that old school
you know I'm saying saying on the whole
I like them beat selection keep it like
that's what it sounds like to me but
like I said you got that [ __ ] bad no
artists from where they come from sound
like where they come from
no we don't even what he's saying is
like the edge I know this is really a
Florida our photo got they stand on the
mat a lot of I like or from a llama I
like data yeah they say this later on
yeah I got hard like man before he
jumped up I when you were doing night we
were working together my house like
every day you know I love day they're
like thank you that's good I work gives
you I like you swear like that Sun
different off what your thoughts on the
reality he's a very polarizing guy right
now I hate him or love them
got nothing bad to say about on because
like I don't care what type of music you
make I respect this also and like that's
what that's what it's about right about
what he don't if you use if you fooled
metal person no matter what he said on
the song I only don't matter like he's
so cooling down to earth like I know you
late like he's a nice kid like that's
all you gotta keep that - a key yes
great event he's a kid and won't let him
live man let a man live yo I know I'd be
living
ok what's gonna fall say did you do a
song ever race trimmer am I missing
something
no we didn't I never did a song race
from but we don't do like so isn't stuff
together like that'd be something out of
here let me know play some Syria to be
dope that light could they got away
they got a different wave now you never
know what this spit would go yeah and I
so unexpected
shut up to my Twitter - who's gonna mix
tape I mean I just have one feature in
this cycle I'm saving the pieces
basically for the air because iPad I
look at it as if I don't need help
telling my store write my story can't be
out something different happens in my
life every day that is real like we need
a we need a rich homie Quan album yeah
yeah are late up lately
our dog is late August early September
I'm gonna call it name it rich as in
spirit ok I've been holding on to the
name like two years like it's gonna
state there's gonna be a discover my
baby and you are your is the I'm pretty
much a gentleman right song yeah 400
songs played its mobile bad I still much
going on like I'm someone stops to go
ahead and start recording you know that
you see with Drake did where he put out
the joint and he know wasn't or was a
Kanye where they were changing oh yeah
like adding a change think that religion
being true because you do have the music
like hey y'all just added two songs to
the playlist I would definitely do that
because like it's like I can change
anytime like you can always just away
but as long as you just think to left
field
yeah if you ever start relatable to the
people I was just relatable man I'm down
and put it up but I don't want to put
like 15 tracks on my debut 15
I've even got to have you been doing it
for six years no Eddie
alright I'm feeling like yeah we still
don't have a I mean we got somebody
mixing some of the songs on something
but it's it it's that time now what's
your favorite song is that to perform I
feel like you you turn up on your live
man
tired of performing certain songs but
what's the favorite record to perform my
song reload reload it okay I like to do
reloaded uh I promise I promise I'll
never start going in reloaders my
favorite song I like I used to feel I
got the old sample beat in it and you
tell anybody put their hands up ladies
rock rock rock rock this is a bar the
hotel night I'm curious what is if you
had to like go to jail for five years I
don't know for getting into a fight with
the Birdman forget bigger loss or
whatever or any of that but God forbid
you had to get locked in but you had to
take an iPod or five albums on it with
five albums would you put your favorite
five albums of all time I will have to
be I like to plot all eyes on me yes yes
Oh about this outcast thang on your
stink on you guy over tonight I'm just
thinking
aquila nice the best okay I mean in my
opinion is equipment I have a third
album alright third yeah I like those
great what's one that's the best one
there's so long I mean dreams on there I
got oh what about the one by uh live
like I told you hands in and yes that is
on ATLiens I like that that's a good
this yesterday oh I like [ __ ] for uh
first I forgot now but it's so much
[ __ ] I love [ __ ] delving right now
like who was made my top I'd rather you
to meet Rick Ross me so long sorry I
thought about country I got a quick
question since you ain't you from
Atlanta because I had a small
debate okay because they were telling me
what's the natural weight was one of the
worst on the rap no no no I didn't say
it was one of the worst southern rappers
put listen he tried to say pastor Troy
was one of the basin he's an ATL no he's
an ATL legend but is he top 10 but I'm
not a rapper of all time you need spot
no that was the debate debate with Josh
rash pastor Troy like evil evil desolate
no you guys were like like you he's that
top 10 selling rapper of all time though
if not the people to never just you know
shut them down
I think pastor Troy would have been
light source okay yeah
but but listen if we're talking we had
look I'm not a pastor Troy friend I am I
am I'm a passive person a line that's
fine
everyone has her opinion I think it's
safe to say he's not top 10 southern
rapper ball he's not even top 10 Atlanta
rapper of all time the [ __ ] out he was
like but it is I gear I got there won't
let me see that boy though I don't K
every birthday banks he done a perform
no pastor's wait here anybody know out
there with every rapper that is on that
top 10 list is going to show some love -
or the exact words they are just like
[ __ ] show love to uh you know
the [ __ ] Beastie Boy and you know I'd
like Shaka Zulu - rapper of all time
just don't like personally I like I'm
not I love a trial but come on come on
yo man I like hang on like like what he
did and I was deeper canoes y'all to my
did show up to Luke all the time like I
grew up listening to Luke yeah but Luke
is not [ __ ] dope like my long good
master is two different things
no more like Luke I mean I'd like like
for what he did for the culture I mean
he [ __ ] knock down some barriers for
you know banned in the USA and ship like
Luke is he making like class I mean he
just want to do they Kelly I'm saying
that just nothing we can hurt me yeah he
said yeah I run you know we've been
working all day yeah okay so okay so now
we got three albums well you got you
gotta give you two more up after dinner
on what's why I say that old-school
boozy Tupac and now casting on you okay
Ross Rick roses or anyone there one more
tough Naza little metal man little
matter
yeah really really nice you know rounded
out I tried to go light I got like I got
some north
you got some west coast down south you
27:27 yeah so it's like a different
genre like and grew up on but not like a
lot of up north like a life families to
like thank you any guy oh no you wanna
kinda like nah but I'm gonna flame 51st
like 50 first album man get rich doctor
iron that's really like fire fire hero
city was so focused in
you just keep that nanananana bro man
listen yes bangs on those if he's put
out recently is nothing the best few
years when you got out like that though
you tell me it like this the way like
his first Alvers two albums you know the
next night I was hard to this way don't
worry had nothing no ironic from her she
was crazy the mixtape [ __ ] but then
after that you can [ __ ] lump I've all
in old ammunition I'm like fifty fan too
but you can't spend a lot of sure that's
messed up man
except it's that this guy made the
craziest statement what did I say me and
Dre were telling you he there's no way
his top ten southern rapper of all time
or even Atlanta rapper of all time
anyone all your great because you're
crazy me later
and you do it in bed yeah you got he'll
be how you say [ __ ] impact how did
you say [ __ ] impact these are artists
I felt the impact of Master P when I was
a little kid in my Bergen format
repeating the top [ __ ] list ever hell
no no but no happy for me yeah I can rap
ghetto dopes from front the [ __ ] back
but you're not like but I know like in
the feeling out the music like method
she must be more Ville like here be talk
to you for this how about this
Khachaturian has never in his life ever
dropped an album or full body of work
even close as good as ghetto dope for
master p ghetto dope dog the orange man
to be like sick no he's not sick he's no
impact
he's but he was a hobo yeah a lot he'd
be and that's why he's more knowledge
only one grew up the master p listen to
the mass appeal oh you have no limits
sneakers when i was again yeah okay i'll
use in okay well you got them let's what
it help you felt the impact thanks in
school how much ghetto dope and MP no
are and we're on my question
alright which remain cool we got agree
disagree on which laws you said you've
got that you know man you know who do
didn't age well what's over the chakra
my god he might be the worst rapper of
all time so l0 silk rockers terrible
yeah he was blamed on the good looks at
your cool don't baby bomb baby I brought
that yeah I'll they bought MJ
no we don't know like when I brought
them up here you know who's way more
[ __ ] to in a basket or a pond mgg
obviously they're from Tennessee but
wait liar nighttime they did a little
boy [ __ ] it was edgy might be like some
of the two most about the mcs ever hey I
was doing like a pond MJ yeah yeah yeah
okay [ __ ] great music you gave that
to some love and I'm going to give you
props for that cuz you didn't come here
and give them some love but my easy
getaway you're a pastor Troy I do pass
well you know I love you man we get you
a new building every time a oh I see the
bill the reason I said oh yeah only part
of pastor drive [ __ ] with is the fact
I'm a wrestling fan they carry around
like a WCW alien ship I look like [ __ ]
the real goal it would examine you like
a real gold own I own like an actual
boat championship belt and it's heavy
it's fun it is it's not little risotto
not real might not real goes oh oh no no
no don't stop doing pencil I don't know
past when he got his money right he
bought a real pill but just so you know
like the actual WWE belt is in real gold
so it is plated oh yeah real fine oh man
neither would decide it man we love you
past
we know you PT come on George oh boy
yeah yeah now I don't want to give it
out only wait on that one
I got future on the futures on the AE
you got a big hello daddy
yeah once upon a time you know that's a
big deal you just hear just put me on a
little tape mmmm
hey uh what's a DJ ESCO yeah but got a
studio we locked in there like Twitter
song man you chop without mixing
together glad that got figured out
that's all it's all getting older man
you know you get old demanding it's
about expanding man I think the people
got everybody's ear and it was Shauna I
don't know I didn't lie not hip to this
is with their future rich homie Quan
like well they're you're trying to say I
was trying to make it one you know
in a sounded take the same mom looks
really under fan designer some daily
differences clear differences in the
back y'all sound alike at all it's been
the way you are but even if I did like
I'm from Alana Florida been cool but
like for Lana
Beth know your design a sound check not
only are you from Italy but you're kind
of like close and it like oh yeah I got
a bed inside a home bro you know I'm
signing song C's you know I am no mute
why don't you it's like you got 12
records together I mean all 12 gonna
come out put out a [ __ ] mixtape no
it's bigger than a like it's bigger than
that right now though I rather dedicate
my was problem jointer loosely or just
savings he's got a build up and drop
them here and there hmm yeah hey man you
know I don't know it's time the music
time is oh I enjoy working with a little
dope that's okay we held here to our
futures on the album so we got it we got
a confirmation that whatever beef that I
was not aware of people created but to
watch like in one line it was a very
know just like the air look at this
person yeah it was like attention but it
has ever been like an actual rap beat
that you've been a part of that you had
you know I know man I will never forget
I will never forget the first time me
goes did club sky in [ __ ] Tampa I'm
not going to say which member of the
mingoes
all I'm gonna say is they took a
sprinter from Atlanta to Tampa Florida
and these [ __ ] got shorted by
the club for whatever amount of money
and I watched these guys pull a [ __ ]
ak-47 and put it to the club one who
said hmm goddamn you know but now I know
you from nowhere don't reckon I'm just
happy because this is y'all [ __ ] let
I'll be watching the vital and [ __ ] on
it later
oh man yo man we just talking about them
you got a lot of guns in Atlanta man
what is going on I don't know the
youngest yes all the jumpers are in
Atlanta man they so see that's how they
want a chopper and I lands more to life
so I don't encourage none of you do you
feel like the fact that everyone does
have these choppers it's kind of you
know la is not a safe place no def ray
and it seem like it's as bad as it is it
is bad but maybe because everybody got
their protector yeah but at the same
time - Tara
I bet it's bad I'm sorry now it's bad
everyone enlighten us rappers play a big
you know what a big role in media
holding no guns and still a church after
the V goes to for not cleaning up that
pointer [ __ ] dad even up all honey
their last guns no more they on that
because when they first came out I was
like yo these kids are gonna get killed
out here it is brawling playing you know
I'm sure I don't wanna you don't want to
mess with their mind
yeah you know what you got going for
yourself so you just have to resend it
yourself which is Rican school I just
think about what you do before you do so
in August way nice early september we're
gonna get the album file album finally
is what's the difference between being
on a capital which is obviously a
machine legendary record label and then
be on an independent label that you know
I would definitely say like man
independent you just put stuff up right
capital no you don't cross the t's and
that these guys we don't have to be all
ought to be but I've learned so much by
being in a building that I didn't know
that I knew so much there's been
independent but I don't know it took me
so long huh you know thank you 27
Brighton take you so long but if you
thank you how to thank right yeah he's
got I made my first meeting it was like
y'all got 2013 well so just so like even
like now but I'm glad I learned what I
learned you know I'm saying the
independent I like because if I would
start off my screen to a deal I don't
think I'd be here to talk about woman be
having is gonna be ready
not a 360 deal with capital no no I know
I know there's a yachty treatment side
you can't even say yeah I didn't know
the baby was old you know yeah Addison
audience on greasy straight man we'll
look let's get into this new record man
oh yeah right now man we got replay
coming nobody yeah rich homie Quan you
glad you're back you're looking good
thank you you got caught that hair again
man I hereby yeah this is I'm getting
old like the head knocked out five years
so I guess they're gonna 22 so you got
to go with the girls man you can't go
everybody off the hair too
huh that's what it was like man first I
had that you know I had my own could in
Atlanta you had everybody
when you're going out you know you're
just an app you don't call me just
emphasize you're going to Atlanta - or
everybody goes oh that's when I grow up
my house because I didn't want to look
like nobody you know answer right now
just cut it all off but like a new
artist so when they start cutting they
have you know they I'm gonna grow my own
back up there is this all about then do
you like be new here yeah yeah the
ladies little bit like my demon going
crazy is that the main source of strange
your DMS my straight I mean females that
you haven't [ __ ] already oh yeah I'll
call it like cuz I'm respond to D my
dual attachments right oh yeah you know
I got in your bumble no - but Thursday's
he's a thirsty bastard over there both
of them I'm not offend there bro yeah
Tim that's my antenna for like older
people attendance that you're on tinder
why would I be on tinder never been on
Tim never been on yours in no I'm not
[ __ ] engaged I've never in my life
been I think cynical got in case like
the name yeah like I don't like to uh
but you are a bumble bumble was
different bumble had never heard of that
Islam was when the women pick you okay I
thought that was a different Lane right
oh so instead of the page like you said
the page you you could say oh I like you
but she has to like you back that she
has to write you froze the bomb would
like bumble bee I don't [ __ ] you know
like man I try to break the net I'm not
active on bumble I'm not active but I
tried it's a hell yeah what's in it did
try it out you should try it out what we
get a nice and dirty today now let me go
you little beyond ball we don't really
make you stairs because the ladies I'll
pick you is like I look I just fall back
like I think you cute and didn't want to
talk to you and Michael I know from our
blood they see on been paid like
clunking on that one man I can tell my
ala t yeah ever except it was gone now
but I'm saying I couldn't go on a grab
for Mike come on get the hell I know I'm
gonna get ease on it if it was bad is
like boy they're going to be fair most
of the [ __ ] on Backpage all those
photos are not actually I know you get
catfished nothing I need help my hair
you just tell oh you didn't know like
friend who I would not mention his name
to serve you we're getting married and
we took him to Vegas for a bachelor
party
and I tried to get him some hookers off
back page and I called the number and I
was like listen I live here this is when
I lived in Vegas I like I live here I
know the game this this
you in this photo I swear to [ __ ] god
if you come to this hotel room and you
are anybody else you're gonna get shown
the door look short enough it wasn't huh
gigantic chef mooking [ __ ] comes to the
door but some tiny little white [ __ ] we
didn't even want to [ __ ] a little
give you a two for one two for one not
to that and then the business had the
nerve I'm like y'all get the [ __ ] outta
yeah we made a pink I showed in my
computer on my clothes [ __ ] they try to
make us pay for uh for their gasps oh my
kind of a more rich homie Quan oh that
was a fun interview I'm now putting that
was a great interview oh yes we may need
you to get your plates back man I'm
definitely good a bit man you know I'm
saying it takes time though you know
take time do you have a good
relationship wife and lucci because
obviously he's on my kind of like the
big I know label I'm not we got no but
he's a man over there nothing to the man
you guys had a relationship prior to the
legal situation to transpire DJ's job
you build with labelmates
defend laughs magical always on music
I'm released me you know I wish on the
bench right now
he's demanding for sure hey don't die as
you hope you rated tables yeah badly I
hopefully you don't get another you know
I've been thinking there and say it
again I know I'm putting so many in a
good situation and I'm saying we'll see
ya everybody got different standards you
only laugh it as if everybody's on it
happen so long you know things about
just how you multiply everything you
know then Scrabble up man for that man
rich homie Quan we have to party right
92 drink